- mon cher fils, cela va sembler
étrange mais il y a ce secret mais les
hommes de cette famille peuvent voyager dans le temps
Wow Tim vas-tu faire mon dos d'accord arrête
comment pourrais-je réellement aller dans un
endroit sombre pense au moment où tu vas
à et tu te retrouveras là Tim nous
faisons mon dos oh bien
c'est ma région et tu as d'abord pensé que
tu serais vraiment génial si cela pouvait m'aider à
trouver une petite amie Wow
massif je suis Tim je suis Mary Mary le nom de ma
mère  Je te rappelle ta
mère oh tu aurais dû
réfléchir plus euh je suis Tim Mary j'aime tes
yeux et j'aime aussi le reste de ton visage
et je n'ai même pas regardé plus bas
je peux aller dans la chambre et  mettre mon
nouveau pyjama et puis dans une minute vous pouvez
entrer et les enlever je suis sûr que ce
sera mieux la prochaine fois
mon bravo certaines personnes en font un vrai
gâchis la première fois contre c'est Mary
bon seigneur vous  tu es jolie oh non c'est juste
que j'ai beaucoup de mascara et de rouge
à lèvres jetons un coup d'oeil oh oui bon tu
dois être  très prudent quand vous l'utilisez
l'effet papillon qui est une vraie
recette pour le désastre
c'est si bon de vous voir nous ne nous sommes jamais rencontrés
avant
Oh non
chaque jour jusqu'à hier est perdu
comme pour tout le monde
nous n'avons pas fait je ne
Je ne sais pas que vous devez l'utiliser pour des choses qui, selon
vous, rendront votre vie comme
vous le souhaitez.
J'espère que je vous reverrai.
tuer Hitler ou baiser Hélène de
Troie malheureuse
si nous avons cette conversation avant